see i remember i remember [ __ ] like
fraggle rock and uh
let the music play worries for another
day let the music play down at fraggle
rock you don't remember fraggle we had
fraggles were in the 80s
oh no i have no idea you should check
out the fraggles it was kind of twisted
and weird
that's something that i guess i never
really learned much about was like old
like 80s kid like kid stuff like i'm
always like because i've been told like
the biggest thing we get with the show
is did you have to do your homework did
you have to study 80s pop culture music
movies and what's your answer
no
no because i already knew all of it
because my parents i mean they like any
songs they play in the radio they'd be
playing that stuff they'd show me the
movies that they loved when they were
kids like i always compare like people
always ask like they're baffled that we
might have an understanding of what the
80s were like but the people who were in
the 80s they're just they're they love
to talk about the fact that they're from
the 80s already
that's true
they're very proud bunch what movies do
you love from the 80s that you went back
and watched and go wow this holds up
like i'm sure back to the future well i
mean all the classics but that's
everything those are the movies that
like define the generation i want to get
down like the nitty-gritty stuff and
like find like really weird niche movies
that were like i still haven't like i
like of course back in the future
goonies stand by me e.t
uh
i'm trying to think of some other good
ones i mean never ending story that's
always great ah
the never-ending story look at the song
yeah but that movie is one of it was one
of my favorite movies
it
forever i don't know why it didn't scare
the crap out of me because i was a very
frightened child of
very basic things like the count from
sesame street
still scares me
how can i count the ways
one i have an irrational fear of the
count from sesame really
because i had a nightmare about when i
was five